we've got mask mandates vaccine mandates
vaccine passports social distancing new
rules popping up everywhere for we
you the american people
at the request of the bite
administration and their apparent
supervisors in the cdc and the nih cdc
now saying even if you're fully
vaccinated yeah you can still get covert
nih is advising parents to wear masks
inside their own home wow okay the delta
variant yes it's very serious they tell
us i agree but for some reason their
concerns their mandates magically
completely utterly disappear when it
comes to our southern border as we speak
now a 25-year record number of illegal
immigrants are pouring across that
border most unvaccinated many infected
with covet 19 in fact 20 percent of
migrant children now testing positive
for covid and 18 percent of families
that is double the positive uh
positivity rate in the entire us but the
biden administration just cannot be
bothered to find the real solution in
other words the one he inherited and got
rid of let me be very clear tonight
any american that gets covered any
american that needs to be hospitalized
god forbid any american that ends up
dying from covert that is traced back to
joe's open borders
that's joe biden's fault he is now
officially putting american lives at
risk with his open borders policies in
the middle of this pandemic and then
dispersing people all over the country
and not testing most of the people at
all no mandates for illegal immigrants
only for american citizens and look at
your screen we are seven months into
this crisis in the middle of a pandemic
and this is what our border facilities
look like right now migrants literally
stacked on top of each other in small
rooms and jail cells and cages that joe
biden built until they dispense and
disperse people all over the country and
get this according to a new report from
the daily caller after days packed
inside these overcrowded biden cages and
facilities well migrants are ultimately
then transported on private unmarked
jets to abilene texas and then loaded
onto buses and commercial flights with
destinations all across the u.s again
with a high rate of covert positivity
this is madness because it's draconian
measures for you the american people no
testing for people that are breaking our
laws not respecting our sovereignty or
our borders i guess this is what america
last policies look like in tacoma
washington one overflow migrant facility
where more than a thousand migrants were
transferred they are now experiencing
what is a massive coven 19 outbreak
according to the seattle times hardly a
conservative news outlet while the
government released about 570 detainees
it deemed at high risk for contracting
covert 19
the harm is done without a doubt the
border crisis is the single largest
nationwide super spreader event in the
history of the u.s but the covet
warriors and the biden administration is
pretending like none of this is
happening no crisis at all i don't see
any crisis here even worse they're
actually encouraging migrants to come by
raising the limit on refugees ending the
very successful trump era stay in mexico
policy reinstituting the catch and
release program under obama that donald
trump stopped now it's not even catch
and release it's process and release in
fact at least 50 000 illegal immigrants
have been dispersed all over the u.s u.s
without so much as a court date our
system is just not capable of processing
the over million plus illegal immigrants
that have entered our country since joe
biden's inauguration by the way these
are the illegal immigrants the only the
ones we know about that were actually
processed and detained briefly by law
enforcement we have no idea how many
illegal immigrants slipped across
undetected because all those resources
pretty much are in just a few areas and
tonight our federal government loves to
scold florida loves to scold texas not
taking kovitz seriously enough why
because governor abbott governor
desantis won't force anyone to wear
masks in school
but given this crisis at the southern
border migrants packed in cages small
rooms not tested then dispersed
nationwide well it's obvious it's clear
it's transparent joe biden clearly
doesn't really give to adam shifts about
the spread of coven 19 unless he can use
it to bludgeon his political enemies or
blame trump to that end it appears that
the cdc was caught red-handed padding
the daily covert numbers right out of
florida hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else